[Música]
ficou muito claro até aqui que trabalhar
bem com pessoas diferentes é o segredo
para o sucesso no futuro
já era no presente e ficou claro também
que irá que a vertical está falida
eu quando era pequena pensava quando eu
crescer vou mandar vai ser a hora da
vingança e acabou né
pois é como é que a gente vai fazer
então com que as pessoas trabalhem com a
gente pela gente pelos nossos projetos
nesse novo cenário que vem se
apresentando os segredos são os laços
são as conexões ea imagem nos ajuda a
nos conectar com o outro
quando a gente fala de imagem a gente
rapidamente pensa no look do dia no
vestuário na aparência
se isso faz parte da imagem mas não é
por si só a imagem vai muito além da
roupa
o nosso comportamento nosso modo de
chegar num ambiente como agente
cumprimenta um cliente
a gente dá aquele aperto de mão forte ou
aquele aperto de mão um molinho gente
sorrir tem uma cara fechada tem algum
time nervoso
tudo isso influencia na imagem
influencia também a maneira como a gente
se porta no ambiente como a gente se
alimenta influencia também os nossos
horários a gente cumprir horário não
influencia também o nosso modo de falar
eu falo muito rápida papas não haja
ganho enquanto aquelas pessoas que falam
vagarosamente é aquela pessoa que fala
alto que passa uma imagem muito
diferente daquela pessoa que fala
suavemente o nosso modo de falar é um
componente importante da imagem pessoal
então nós temos a aparência o
comportamento até a postura física o
nosso modo de falar eo nosso conteúdo
todos esses são elementos da imagem
pessoal
agora quando a gente fala em estabelecer
conexão através da imagem pessoal
primeiro a gente tem que passar por um
nó um grande nó imagem pessoal que são
as interpretações que a gente faz da
imagem dos outros e esse nome é muito
profundo
quero ver vocês vão me ajudar aqui o que
os olhos não vêem perfeito mas quem vê
cara olha que nós não se deve julgar um
livro mas uma imagem fala mais do que
mil palavras
olha quantos nós a gente tem imagem
pessoal
isso porque a gente está o tempo todo
interpretando o outro de forma errada ou
sendo interpretado de forma errada
também e eu vou confessar que eu também
faço isso com a gente eu também julga os
outros embora trabalho nessa área há 20
anos eu continuo olhando para as pessoas
também faz meu julgamento e vou
compartilhar uma história com vocês uma
história que aconteceu no workshop
alguns anos atrás
para exemplificar essa questão de como a
gente julga imagem dos outros eu também
faço isso apesar de trabalhar com 20
anos e imagem pessoal e nesse workshop
sentou na minha frente aquele
participante que todo palestrante deseja
ter na vida
desanimado eu olhei pra aquela pessoa
pensei assim está desanimada porque está
doente né
pode acontecer está cansada a gente
começou a falar de postura começa a
falar de comportamento ea pessoa
desanimada aí a mudar de assunto foi
para a imagem da comunicação e ela
desanimada aí eu pensei vai ver que ela
não gosta do assunto todo mundo que
gosta de imagem desenvolvimento pessoal
mudamos então pra falar a respeito de é
moda corporativa e ela então bufou de
novo aí eu pensei gente que diz respeito
né
como é uma pessoa vem para o trabalho
porque era um treinamento de uma empresa
e senta com uma postura dessa como ela
vai performar ao longo do ano
vai-se péssima atitude dela e também
passou pela minha cabeça foi ver que não
gosta de mim é comigo nem todo mundo é
obrigado a gostar de mim
passadas algumas horas com essa pessoa
chegamos na parte de maquiagem e usando
tudo que eu falo pra vocês eu resolvi
sobrepor as impressões da imagem convidá
la para ser nossa modelo de maquiagem e
ela então levantou e disse ai que bom
eu estava precisando eu falei pra ela e
perguntei perceba que você está assim um
pouco chateado aqui que aconteceu e ela
respondeu a três meses atrás eu me casei
e há um mês eu fiquei viúva e ela tava
lá ela estava se aguentando para um
trabalho novo um cargo novo num
treinamento de desenvolvimento pessoal
ela me deu além de uma lição de vida é
um presente muito grande que se chama
contexto que a gente conseguia entender
tudo o que está acontecendo com a pessoa
porque normalmente quando a gente faz o
julgamento do outro que a gente sabe é
muito pouco
a gente não tem um contexto de verdade
quantos de nós sabemos a história do
colega de trabalho do nosso lado
de repente aquela pessoa toda feliz que
parece que não leva a vida a sério está
com uma mãe internada com câncer
quantas vezes a gente olha para um
cliente que a gente acha mal encarado
mas ele é idêntico você inclusive torce
mesmo time
quem somos nós para julgar o outro somos
perfeitos
somos acima de todos então queria
combinar com vocês que a partir de agora
a gente vai fazer um juramento que a
gente nunca mais vai julgar os outros
pela imagem pessoal
quem está comigo levanta a mão por
gentileza
vamos repetir eu juro que nunca mais
julgarei as pessoas pela imagem pessoal
nunca mais
julgarei a cara feia do meu chefe
depois que apresentar uma idéia nunca
mais
julgar é a cara irônica do meu cliente
quando apresentar o meu preço tem gente
já tá apaixonada mão estão percebendo
que é impossível fazer esse juramento é
tão impossível que mesmo as pessoas
muito obrigada viu agradeço de coração
foi corajoso caridosa né
a boa intenção prevaleceu mas ao sair
daqui e ir para o primeiro restaurante e
padaria você vai olhar para os pratos e
falar nem está gostoso vou pegar esse
esse aqui não tá tão legal não
isso porque nós comemos primeiro com os
mais um modo a imagem pessoal
então o que a gente pode fazer é
aprender a lidar com esses nós esses nós
vão continuar acontecendo porque nós
nascemos fisiologicamente uma glândula
instalada no nosso cérebro pra julgar a
imagem do outro essa foi a nossa
primeira forma e sempre será nossa
primeira forma de comunicação quem tem
filhos aqui todos nós desde pequenos
utilizamos a leitura facial como uma
forma de comunicação para entender se a
gente está mandando bem ou não e isso
continua até hoje
nos primórdios na pré-história gente
usava isso com uma maneira de nos
defender
e de fato foi isso que nos fez chegar
até aqui
o cérebro além de julgar o outro ele
julga no negativo é o positivo é só
gente curtir o negativo é o que faz a
gente cuidar da gente ser precavido
antigamente a gente olhava com um
dinossauro falava e se vai me comer
então vou pelo outro lado
hoje a gente olha que uma pessoa fala é
só vai me assaltar eu vou atravessar a
rua a gente continue
usando esses artifícios com uma forma de
defesa
e esse julgamento vai continuar
justamente por causa dessa glândula
instalada no nosso cérebro
todos nós vamos fazer esses julgamentos
mas que eu quero negociar aqui com vocês
é o veredito
então quero passar três dicas pra gente
poder trabalhar essa questão tão forte
que a imagem pessoal seja no
relacionamento pessoal ou profissional
93% da nossa comunicação é não verbal
ela é a imagem e vai continuar sendo por
isso vamos cuidar disso para não fazer
falsos julgamentos e conseguir fazer
conexões com as pessoas apesar dos nós
então dica número 1 da segunda chance
às vezes a gente olha para a cara da
pessoa não vai com a cara dela
o santo não bate mas quantas vezes você
foi mal julgado na primeira impressão
quantas vezes as pessoas chegaram para
você depois de um pouco de intimidade
falaram assim a menina vou te falar
primeira vez que eu te conheci de ág
medida a e primeira vez que a cheia
teorias e achei você tão bravo não
queria trabalhar com você
se as pessoas erram em relação a vocês
nós podemos errar em relação a elas
por isso de segunda chance de a terceira
a quarta a quinta a outra dica é nem
tudo é com você
se a pessoa tiver com uma cara feia isso
não significa que ela não gostou de você
isso não significa que ela não tenha
gostado do seu projeto pode ser
inclusive que ela tenha gostado tanto
ela está com uma cara fechada pensando
como é que eu vou quebrar contrato com
outro fornecedor pra te contratar
pode ser que seu chefe esteja com uma
cara fechada porque naquela hora de uma
pontada aqui na barriga ele se sentiu
mal podem ser tantas coisas antes de ser
agente
mas o que a gente faz é sempre olhar o
outro através da gente nós utilizamos o
filtro pessoal réus são os nossos
costumes a nossa cultura a forma como a
gente foi educado a nossa personalidade
portanto eu olho pra alguém eu vejo
cara fechada logo penso que não gosta de
mim eu vejo o outro bufando eu penso
quem bufa é porque está desanimado mas
isso é o que você pensa
esse é o que você vê é a realidade é
muito maior do que o nosso espectro
a terceira dica é seja proativo e busque
contexto a gente precisa saber a
história toda antes de bater o martelo
busque informações sobre essa pessoa
hoje o facebook google o colega do lado
outras pessoas que trabalharam com esse
cliente você tem tantas informações a
respeito dessa pessoa busque da própria
pessoa
o que você achou até agora com essa
intenção com esse movimento que você
espera com isso que eu te falei
busque proativamente esse contexto dessa
forma os nós vão continuar existindo mas
a gente vai conseguir sobrepor isso
primeiro pra nos valorizar para nos
ajudar porque é só criando laços que a
gente vai ter sucesso no presente e no
futuro do trabalho
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]